hey guys today I'm back with another
liquid nitrogen experiment grant
Thompson aka the king of random has died
grants brother Mark told TMZ the
youtuber had gone paragliding on Monday
and never returned
making videos for the last 7 years have
been one of the most challenging but
most rewarding things that are done with
my life there are a lot of ups and downs
in a youtuber journey but you do stuff
with me through them all that's why
you're the best on Tuesday a minute long
video was uploaded to Grant's YouTube
channel the king of random breaking the
news that gran had died the description
read it is with great sadness to inform
everyone that grant Thompson passed away
last night grant had great love and
appreciation for his fans we invite you
to share your thoughts for grant and the
channel in the comments please do a
random act of love or kindness today in
honor of the king of random grants
legacy will live on in the channel and
the global community he created
[Music]
the king of randoms how to DIY and
science experiment videos raked in over
11 million subscribers now this is not
one of those experiments that I would
encourage you to try at home this I
would classify as very very dangerous
and what they say for experts only their
most popular video of all time how to
make Lego gummy candy I'm going to show
you how to take a few simple ingredients
and make mountains and mountains of your
own custom gummy candies at home
following the news of grants death
YouTube tweeted were deeply saddened to
learn of the tragic loss of grant
Thompson a gifted passionate and
endlessly curious creator we send our
deepest condolences to his loving family
the king of random team and fans
[Music]
you